tron
[Musique]
cal âge
cal yesterday today tomorrow
c'est l'expression préférée de mon ami
javid 1 il habite délit c'est ce qu'il
me répond répond à chaque fois que je
lui demande la date de livraison de mots
cachemire call h
cal hier aujourd'hui ou demain
j'ai compris j'ai compris qu'en lindy
calme est aussi bien le jour d'avant ou
le jour d'après aussi bien hier que
demain âge au centre c'est le présent
c'est le principal j'avais de
m'expliquer le présent en inde permet
d'avancer dans la bonne direction
j'en ai fait mon interprétation
comment m'approprier bon nouveau temps
comme handicapés je reviens de deux
accidents vasculaires cérébraux
je dois lire parce que je sais pas très
bien le dire comme ça en août 2014
j'ai eu une première rupture d'anévrisme
premier truc en décembre 2015
j'ai dû être opéré à nouveau
c'était du bien et ça s'est bien passé
mais au détour un peu de cette opération
j'ai subi un deuxième avc
je me suis bien réveillé mais un peu
différente
officiellement je suis devenu une
handicapée cognitives
j'ai perdu l'automatisme des mots une
aphasie une aphasie doublée d'une
émotivité exacerbée depuis trois ans je
dois réapprendre à mon rythme j'y passe
un certain temps je passe mon temps à la
recherche des mots c'est mon combat qu
al haj cale le passé comme le futur sont
mechal merci j'avais dû à raison hier et
demain sont mes soutiens pour
aujourd'hui
j'ai fini par comprendre
je dois vivre en même temps les trois
âges de ma vie je suis à la fois une
enfant une adulte et une centenaire call
calme de la partie d'hier c'est l'enfant
comme une enfant je réapprends les mots
à l'école toutes les semaines comme une
enfant je suis émotive à fleur de peau
il y en a certains qui le savent très
bien
comme une enfant ma spontanéité et sans
limite
je demande de l'attention quand j'en ai
besoin je demande de l'aide
si besoin je suis libre comme une enfant
imaginez comprenez mémos sont des
moustiques
je fais fraises de mes phrases ma tête
est en vrac et mes émotions aussi
je suis une pacanes à cannes ma langue
à khanaqinne iq et le cal du futur alors
qu'angers s'entend et que personne ne
s'en aperçoit il y a beaucoup de fatigue
depuis mon accident il y a plus de temps
de re il n'y a plus de temps de repos
pour ma tête
chaque mot implique une recherche un
stress un mot égale un stress imaginez
le stress pour une phrase ça me fatigue
et il ya aussi le rythme lent pour faire
simple tout me prend du temps imaginez
au supermarché on me demande de me
regarde je me regarde de travers parce
que je ne réponds pas assez vite à la
caissière je retarde tout le monde je
suis plus vieille que mon âge mais mon
âge on sont présents c'est que je suis
adulte
j'ai 49 ans je suis handicapé cognitive
handicap cognitif certes mais je ne suis
pas une autre je suis pas sur une autre
planète
non non c'est bien les pieds sur terre
un peu trop même je dois vous avouer 40
kg qui me sont tombés dessus
depuis mon accident enfin aujourd'hui
j'utilise mon expérience de chef
d'entreprise pour organiser mon cerveau
je suis l'entrepreneuse de ma tête
je travaille tous les jours pour avancer
pour construire la praye trouver ma
place je compris je cours je construis
je construis je construis mes projets au
présent un jour après l'autre un sujet
après l'autre donc passé et futur se
conjugue au présent
ils me soutiennent pour avancer je vis
en même temps les trois âges de ma vie
je me sens comme les bretons qui vivent
toutes les saisons dans une journée
cela ne les empêche pas d'être heureux
j'ai en fait c'est ma méthode mon cal
âge
cal parce que j'écoute l'enfant parce
que j'accepte je suis plus vieille que
mon âge
alors je construis ma vie au présent je
construis ma nouvelle vie à mon rythme
j'ai l'impression d'avoir trouvé une
vraie méthode de vie vivre au présent
dans son simple call âge qu'elle merci
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]